now at the end of our podcast we do a
thing called unhelpful advice it's a
email people ask questions and we give
them advice it doesn't have to be
helpful it can be whatever you want I'm
yeah so go ahead Gilbert unhelpful
advice with Nick
Rutherford second city this is from
always promoting that's quality this is
from a female listener we'll call her HB
I have a co-worker who I became
extremely close friends with throughout
that time I made myself emotionally
available for her in times of hardship
in her life and really made an effort to
be as good of a friend as her as I could
when a traumatic event came up in my
life she was nowhere to be found I let
her know that I felt unwanted as a
friend and she expressed that she didn't
have the emotional capacity to be there
for me in the same way it just felt
unfair and she completely withdrew from
the friendship after that and basically
replaced our friendship with another
co-worker it's hard because I constantly
have to see we're at work and we don't
say anything to each other anymore as
the [ __ ] King as the slept king and the
dawn what should I do love you guys HB
that seems like a tldr for me was a
tiara so she had a friendship that was
burgeoning and then it didn't didn't
work out Fran was not there it wasn't
there was no reciprocity yeah it was
betrayal that's what I saw and at the
end of every betrayal there needs to be
victory so yes so will you have to win I
don't know what the dynamics of your
work is I don't know where she works but
at the end of the day you have to come
up and you have to show this woman that
you know that it's her loss okay yeah I
agree with you right I really thing on
in the sense of moving on that's not
what I'm saying
what's John why my my my girlfriend is
very much smarter than me in a lot of
ways and one of the things just like I
like I don't know about you I imagine
we're very similar and so when somebody
like you're trying to be friends with
somebody and they don't you're making a
lot of weird listen to what yours I try
to listen what you're saying when
somebody like for me when somebody I'm
like trying to become friends when
somebody has any pushback of being my
friend cuz I'm like I have no everything
to offer and nothing like I'm just and
if there's any pushback it makes me want
to be their friend more yeah yeah and my
girlfriend has said like the best thing
you can do is wildly ignore them and
then they will come around or whatever
they're whatever so HB your friend or
your ex friend is dealing with their own
insecurities has nothing to do with you
and it makes you want to win you want a
victory so you're gonna keep on pushing
after that friendship you're gonna keep
on chasing that friendship best thing
you can do move on entirely [ __ ] cold
her like cold case or immediately move
on and she'll come around
Elle is the right one yeah yeah that's
exactly what it is - yeah you know kind
of them yeah you have to it's crazy and
I'm not that Johnny Sanchez was my guy
Johnny Sanchez back in the 90s there was
a comic and he was the Dane Cook of The
Comedy Store he was on fire did he like
the Dane Cook of like The Laugh Factory
and he was on fire and everyone used to
all the young guys dorm I used to follow
him around you know want to be his
friend
I would call him he would never call me
back I pray to God right that he would
be my best friend
I remember going on my hands and knees
please god I love this guy this guy's
the coolest and then I just one day just
said [ __ ] this [ __ ] I mean he's a nice
guy he's very funny guy and then I just
went the opposite direction I started my
own thing and then you know years later
I helped him get on MADtv and this and
that but at the end of the day yeah now
I don't chase I don't even think about
him I see Johnny and I hug them I love
them but I just it's like you know I
just I completely moved on from it and
it now we're friends I love them but I
don't have that anymore with that guy
just you got to do that yeah because I
think it's really unattractive when
someone appears needy
yeah of your time you know your
affection or
whatever it's just yeah it seems
exhausting
[Music]